morning y'all just woke up got ready and
now I'm off to go to this agenda
workshop now if you guys don't know what
agenda is agenda is one of those things
where it's huge for people in the
clothing business but they have this
workshop where we get to learn more
about the clothing business that we're
about to be in and um you know for me
I'm not beyond learning more about this
industry because it's fairly new to me
I'm obviously not a fashion guru if it
you know if you guys are surprised by
that long you know but 7:30 in the
morning I fell asleep at 4:30 because I
had to get a lot of work done and I had
to get out the way because this workshop
is going to be all day so you know how
to do that preparatory work but actually
gonna be an awesome day I could tell
what the [ __ ] your food is a dead bird I
just said on camera it's gonna be a good
day and I see a [ __ ] dead bird on the
floor look at that [ __ ] so once you
explain to the camera why are you here
today
destiny so cool that you are going to
attend emerge to learn about stuff gotta
learn about networking with some of the
industry industry giants learning how to
make our shirts a little bit better make
our network call me
I'm gonna have four egg white the lights
please
how much I'm sorry hold on how many egg
whites - I want the real and then
Michael wants a hatch Brown because he's
wet one can have a nonfat latte
what can you poison that - please for as
much [ __ ] as she talks about McDonald's
this [ __ ] just ordered McDonald's oh I
always say that I only like the
cheeseburgers I don't like the McNuggets
I don't like all that other [ __ ] all
you see is the words that you use why
you have to say [ __ ] there's no such
thing as [ __ ] at McDonald's and Joe
would say you're the mother [ __ ] is
that Lee do you don't blame your macros
you know you like that's your [ __ ]
scapegoat for everything oh I'll hit
this car it's my macros thirty seconds
later whoo it's gonna happen eat that
[ __ ] do you mean how you feel you know
you love it Oh lie lie give that
sandwich to Bart bad don't make [ __ ]
dick noises and eat it like hey about
McDonald's I [ __ ] around sponsors you
know how many times we [ __ ] did a
free brand deal for your [ __ ]
ass you know how many views accumulate
it towards McDonald's sponsor us the
least you can do is acknowledge us and
just say a little thank you for the
promotion the free [ __ ] publicity
that we're giving you on our [ __ ]
major media program that's not even I at
least want them to respond to what to
say hey we don't like your [ __ ] [ __ ]
asses or something yep you know what del
Taco follow me on Twitter why can't you
do that [ __ ] Taco Bell said hi oh yeah
yeah Taco Bell said hi they acknowledge
the people that represent them [ __ ] that
[ __ ] called Junior come to us
here
it's automatic
for as long as I know Michael here's
never want to share without a collar
this was younger than he lets my father
she's absolutely insane
so part what did you side to bring us
here come out here learn some stuff it's
not making [ __ ] up pretending like we
know so what did you have her breakfast
today hmm no just I just want you to say
it on camera what did you have for
breakfast today from where hence did you
buy this magical I think is there with
an eye yeah I all right
Swiss cheese
I swear to God we came in at all
McDonald's that's why pop [ __ ]
it's what I marry you
so on the first half the meeting what
did you find the most interesting
I learned that Michael can sleep sitting
down and those are over and over he did
one of these he didn't hit anyone else
other than that something that stood out
to me that we all were kind of shocked
was the biggest [ __ ] sell day
worldwide and seniors day you got a
bunch of lovely ass Chinese mother
[ __ ] on singles day they buy a gift
for themselves and we thought it was
Black Friday that's really big knowing
West which is 2 billion singles day is
nine billion in one day talking buddy
she want that but Quan D where she go
Julia I work out too
I'm fake I'm famous too I'm famous too
that's cool she should just all of us
she goes oh [ __ ] you guys I'm famous too
I'm famous too I got more Instagram
falls in her she whack that's cool want
to appreciate it but you a nest picture
for me though so it doesn't really
matter you ain't a huge fan of nobody
[ __ ] you just after that ass
I'm famous too I know me and Joe we're
famous too there's obviously two
integral members of just killing news
that were completely ignored the two
most favorite members of just kidding me
I'm famous to this [ __ ] take
notes in his dreams I'm visualizing the
words haha let's see you sure
and you're great designing t-shirts you
don't really have as much time to design
the t-shirts because you have to run the
business on the side a lot of times
right kind of one of our favorite parts
of meeting change of food if I get to
look like a baby I mean you get two of
these women always look like a [ __ ]
that's where - god how many times you
have to shave more times a year he has
like maybe ten whiskers and then maybe
five on the other side there's nothing
at all here I'm trying there's like ten
down here like just one others nothing
there do babies come here secrets let me
go you're so I have some coming out now
your hands are so heavy
it's not a manatee
Hey